good afternoon everybody ten days ago
the world watched in horror as men women
and children were massacred in Syria in
the worst chemical weapons attack of the
21st century yesterday the United States
presented a powerful case that the
Syrian government was responsible for
this attack on its own people our
intelligence shows the Assad regime and
its forces preparing to use chemical
weapons launching rockets in the highly
populated suburbs of Damascus and
acknowledging that a chemical weapons
attack took place and all of this
corroborates what the world can plainly
see hospitals overflowing with victims
terrible images of the dead all told
well over 1,000 people were murdered
several hundred of them were children
young girls and boys gassed to death by
their own government this attack is an
assault on human dignity it also
presents a serious danger to our
national security it risks making a
mockery of the global prohibition on the
use of chemical weapons it endangers our
friends and our partners along Syria's
borders including Israel Jordan Turkey
Lebanon and Iraq it could lead to
escalating use of chemical weapons or
their proliferation to terrorist groups
who would do our people harm in a world
with many dangers this menace must be
confronted now after careful
deliberation I have decided that the
United States should take military
action against Syrian regime targets
this would not be an open-ended
intervention we would not put boots on
the ground instead our action would be
designed to be limited in duration and
scope but I'm confident we can hold the
Assad regime accountable for their use
of chemical weapons deter this kind of
been
savior and degrade their capacity to
carry it out our military has positioned
assets in the region the chairman of the
Joint Chiefs has informed me that we are
prepared to strike whenever we choose
moreover the chairman has indicated to
me that our capacity to execute this
mission is not time sensitive it will be
effective tomorrow or next week or one
month from now and I'm prepared to give
that order but having made my decision
as commander in chief based on what I am
convinced is our national security
interests I'm also mindful that I'm the
president of the world's oldest
constitutional democracy I've long
believed that our power is rooted not
just in our military might but in our
example as a government of the people by
the people and for the people and that's
why I've made a second decision I will
seek authorization for the use of force
from the American people's
representatives in Congress over the
last several days we've heard from
members of Congress who want their
voices to be heard I absolutely agree so
this morning I spoke with all four
congressional leaders and they've agreed
to schedule a debate and then a vote as
soon as Congress come back into session
in the coming days my administration
stands ready to provide every member
with the information they need to
understand what happened in Syria and
why it has such profound implications
for America's national security and all
of us should be accountable as we move
forward and that can only be
accomplished with a vote I'm confident
in the case our government has made
without waiting for UN inspectors I'm
comfortable going forward without the
approval of a United Nations Security
Council that so far has been completely
paralyzed and unwilling to hold Assad
accountable as a consequence many people
have advised against taking this
decision to Congress and undoubtedly
they were impacted by what we saw happen
in the United Kingdom this week when the
Parliament of our closest ally failed to
pass a resolution with a similar goal
even as the Prime Minister supported
taking action yet while I believe I have
the authority to carry out this military
action without specific congressional
authorization I know that the country
will be stronger if we take this course
and our actions will be even more
effective we should have this debate
because the issues are too big for
business as usual and this morning John
Boehner Harry Reid Nancy Pelosi and
Mitch McConnell agreed that this is the
right thing to do for our democracy a
country faces few decisions as grave as
using military force even when that
force is limited I respect the views of
those who call for caution particularly
as our country emerges from a time of
war that I was elected in part to end
but if we really do want to turn away
from taking appropriate action in the
face of such an unspeakable outrage then
we must acknowledge the costs of doing
nothing here's my question for every
member of Congress and every member of
the global community what message will
we send if a dictator can gas hundreds
of children to death in plain sight and
pay no price what's the purpose of the
international system that we've built if
a prohibition on the use of chemical
weapons that has been agreed to by the
governments of ninety-eight percent of
the world's people and approved
overwhelmingly by the Congress of the
United States is not enforced make no
mistake this has implications beyond
chemical warfare if we won't enforce
accountability in the face of this
heinous act what does it say about our
resolve to stand up to others who flout
fundamental international rules to
governments who would choose to build
nuclear arms to terrorists who would
spread biological weapons two armies who
carry out genocide we cannot raise our
children in a world where we will not
follow through on the things we say the
words we sign the values that define us
so just as I will take this case to
Congress I will also deliver this
message to the world while the UN
investigation has some time to report on
its findings we will insist that an
atrocity committed with chemical weapons
is not simply investigated it must be
confronted I don't expect every nation
agree with the decision we have made
privately we've heard many expressions
of support from our friends but i will
ask those who care about the writ of the
international community to stand
publicly behind our action and finally
let me say this to the American people I
know well that we are weary of war we've
ended one war in Iraq we're ending
another in Afghanistan and the American
people have the good sense to know we
cannot resolve the underlying conflict
in Syria with our military in that part
of the world there are ancient sectarian
differences in the hopes of the Arab
Spring have unleashed forces of change
that are going to take many years to
resolve and that's why we're not
contemplating putting our troops in the
middle of someone else's war instead
we'll continue to support the Syrian
people through our pressure on the Assad
regime our commitment to the opposition
our care for the displaced and our
pursuit of a political resolution that
achieves a government that respects the
dignity of its people but we are the
United States of America and we cannot
and must not turn a blind eye to what
happened in Damascus now the ashes of
World War we built an international
order and enforce the rules that gave it
meaning and we did so because we believe
that the rights of individuals to live
in peace and dignity depends on the
responsibilities of nations we are
perfect but this nation more than any
other has been willing to meet those
responsibilities so to all members of
Congress of both parties I ask you to
take this vote for our national security
I am looking forward to the debate
in doing so I ask you members of
Congress to consider that some things
are more important than partisan
differences or the politics of the
moment ultimately this is not about who
occupies this office at any given time
it's about who we are as a country I
believe that the people's
representatives must be invested in what
America does abroad and now is the time
to show the world that America keeps our
commitments we do what we say and we
lead with the belief that right makes
might not the other way around we all
know there are no easy options but I
wasn't elected to avoid hard decisions
and neither were the members of the
House and the Senate I've told you what
I believe that our security and our
values demand that we cannot turn away
from the massacre of countless civilians
with chemical weapons and our democracy
is stronger when the president and the
people's representatives stand together
I'm ready to act in the face of this
outrage today I'm asking Congress to
send a message to the world that we are
ready to move forward together as one
nation thanks very much